Jorge Gabriel on drugs says Jordan
please help me I'm 99th percentile
openess and 0 at the percentile and
conscientiousness yeah well how old are
you that's the first thing if you're if
you're young that's because younger
people are less conscientious so that's
one thing to keep in mind if you're very
open like that you need to be doing
something creative but you're gonna have
to learn how to discipline yourself
there's just no way around it and I
would say go do the Future authoring
program that's a good start
and you'll have to learn how to schedule
your time and how to get up at the same
time every day and it's gonna be a real
struggle but you know you you can do it
I've had students who are very high in
openness and low in conscientiousness as
graduate students and they discipline
themselves you need to find something
that you're really interested in that
you're willing to pursue and then you
have to hit it hard so that's what I
would say but do the future Ottoman
program and get yourself a plan and
start to implement it and every time you
fall astray then get back at it and you
know you may have to build up your
conscientiousness over a number of years
and but it's worth doing so